here's the headline giving the middle
finger is a quote god-given right says
Quebec judge stick around
hey town he's welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
absolutely glad to be back yeah I mean
every time I come here it feels like
homecoming to me right I feel like I
grew up in dumb people town I mean we
did too we grew up in them you have made
a career on be lying your accent I
really do believe that is like the core
and are we being accentist I think we
are people are yeah yes I mean that's
kind of the whole thing with me I mean
some even like people that don't know
anything about me sometimes I'll just
say like a multi-syllabic word
yeah five dollar words sometimes for
example multi syllabus
is that a word yeah it literally I was
like is that a word I feel like I've
said this before with you but it's it's
always the Billy Wayne Davis joke for me
where he says uh when somebody says can
I tell you a joke and he goes I don't
know is it based on my dialect
yeah what are your assumptions of what
you think I would want to hear oh no it
happens all the time that happened to
you all the time we actually uh me and
Corey and Drew the guys that I you know
tour with and the well-read yeah we've
also been on the show we uh actually did
a sketch about that like an internet
sketch about that thing because it was
you know happening to us and still does
we're like if you're in a bar in some
other City people are here you're at
here this accident start talking to you
have to come over you pretty much know
what's coming every time like it just
happened to me to buddy's wedding in
Denver a few weeks ago this white lady
at a bar heard me talking next thing you
know she's talking about how black lives
matter is ruining the downtown area yeah
yeah you're like not on the same page
it's a light bulb that goes off in their
head that says he's one of us yeah right
yeah just don't this is okay yeah you'll
love it you'll love it you'll love this
well I love that you're here I think you
helped break down stupid Behavior better
than anybody and we need you right now
so I'm gonna jump into story so I think
the last time you did it was zoom
in the studio but Dan had all three
stories we're doing it differently now
we switched over and now I get us
he's a Randy special you ready yeah and
I love this because
it takes place in Quebec but it could be
the South sure the United States so many
times we've done Midwestern dialects for
something that took place in Australia I
know this England we need a good like
French Canadian good oh yeah with
Australia I feel like that happens a lot
Australia Australia in Bush or Kentucky
it's like the South and also the Florida
of rice
so you ready this is sent in by our
buddy Jake Rooney at Jake Rooney g r o n
thanks buddy thanks buddy sends in a lot
of good ones here is the uh here and and
I again I don't know this is one thing
that as we go through the story I don't
know if the judge is dumb or the guy or
everything is the way it should be this
is like I'm gonna need your guys help on
this thing here's the headline giving
the middle finger is a quote god-given
right says Quebec judge I'm literally
you were going to end that sentence with
says local man yeah no yeah that's
Quebec Justice former says my uncles
aren't Quebec right right I thought
you're gonna says disgraced PE teacher
right
it says stepdad is being led to while
being led Away by cops says Little
League baseball coach and handcuffs yeah
so giving someone the middle finger is a
god-given right that belongs to all
Canadians says intoxicated bus driver
while kids are filed on a bus says
Zamboni driver who just drove into the
boards I mean
so I feel I just love god-given right
because the thing is God gave it to us
as a former Christian that respects
people hey as long as you're not hurting
anybody you love what you love yep but
uh love the music yeah but Rich Mullins
wait have you seen the hill Hillsong
documentary yeah yeah yeah do you know
what that is no Hillsong church was
India that dude's awesome I mean he's
horrible yeah so
it one of the fundamentals is that like
you have free will you have free choice
you choose Jesus Christ as your lord and
say whatever right so I love it I love
when people go it's a god-given right
because there's so many things that if
that if God set all this up and gave
people free will he's like I didn't know
you guys were gonna do that
right that actually isn't one of the you
chose that I didn't give that one to you
there's you guys are making a lot of
decisions on their own so I do believe
and I don't know how much you've
traveled up in the Canada tray but like
I believe that there are obviously
Canada is not all one thing but there
are like two candidates there's hockey
Canada right if you've ever watched the
amazing that's almost all of it sure Z
that is you can find that everywhere
there's hockey Canada and then there's
like nice can't like everyone in Canada
is so nice you just don't sure unless
you're in a hospital match or a rodeo in
Calgary you don't imagine people just
flipping people off in Canada right am I
right we definitely yeah that's
definitely the stereotype we have I'm
one of the funniest so I've only been on
the western part of Canada okay
Vancouver Edmonton Calgary okay I
haven't done the eastern part by like uh
I was there with Corey and during one of
the funniest heckles I've heard because
of context was in one of those Canadian
cities Drew was on stage talking about
how he was a high school quarterback and
some guy in the crowd was like oh yeah
right or something like that and Drew
was like which he was he was a very good
high school but he's like you know he's
not that tall and whatever else so he
then just starts you know tearing into
this guy like I thought Canadians were
supposed to be polite what the [__] you
expect that [__] from dumb ass Americans
but I come up here and I think there'd
be a little decorum you know whatever he
does this whole tirade thing
gets a little bit of life or whatever
but he goes on for a minute and then he
stops and it's super quiet and then you
hear very distinctly the exact same
voice from the crowd go sorry sorry
I'm sorry yeah and then like that just
killed you know but yeah you're right
there's also like the ones that he
waited for the right time yeah Canadians
are funny I mean like Canadians are
hilarious that is a great like timing
Heckle because most people wait don't
you think he meant it or was he really
sorry or was he making a joke I think
that like he genuinely I think he was
genuinely sorry but also was probably
self-aware about it yeah right perfect
joke at the perfect time so in his
ruling Quebec Court Judge Dennis gallace
galasatos you did your best that's all
you tried
g-a-l-i-a Galia satos Galia satos wrote
that not only he wrote this in like a uh
an opinion well he obviously loves to
flick people off Not only was Neil
Epstein with two L's Neil Epstein Neil
waiting
n-e-i-l-l-n-e-a-a-l-l and I would is
that mean the extra L is for loser [__]
I've known I mean I tend to go by Daniel
you know professionally and all this
stuff but I've met a double n Dan and
I'm like why are you double and damn
yeah d-a-n-n the clip that keeps coming
up on my Tick Tock is the Step Brothers
pam pam yeah that's hilarious yeah
that's it but maybe he's Neal Neal
uh found him not guilty the fact that he
was arrested and prosecuted at all was
bewildering Injustice he got arrested
for flipping the birds I mean I agree
with that Steve that's really all he did
going Stone Cold with it I don't know if
you do it to a preschool maybe that's
obscene I don't know at least this is
the first thing if you don't leave this
is the opinion of Judge colors or dicks
right yeah dude that's right some of
them are just they pooping in their own
seats and stuff but the truth is maybe
this become this guy becomes the judge
Galia Santos becomes the official judge
of dumb people town because I'm going to
read the opinion quote to be abundant
abundantly clear it is not a crime to
give someone the finger the judge wrote
wrote in his February 24th ruling
flipping the proverbial bird how much do
you love her proverbial bird I mean
that's the title of this episode
The proverbial bird flipping the
proverbial bird is a god-given charter
enshrined right that belongs to every
red-blooded Canadian have you heard the
term red-blooded Canadian or red blood
and American right yeah and we do like
export like that brand of our dumbass or
anything right yeah you know what I mean
one of the greatest exports yeah right
yeah number one arguably so I thought
Canadians were cold-blooded creatures
uh it may not be civil it may not be
polite it may not be gentlemanly
nevertheless it does not trigger
criminal liability this is the news I
agree right that's right
police arrested Epstein uh a teacher
[Applause]
that's when I knew it was dumb people
down when I heard that on May 18 2021 as
he returned home from a walk early in
the day he had run into a neighbor
Michael nachache
nacc today naccachel
I like that bread that's really thin
that's oh the Chacha bread yeah there
were olives in it so expensive at arawan
Rosemary all right so who lived in the
same Beaconsfield Quebec Street and with
whom he had had previous conflict be
sure this guy has beef yeah right the
Chacha swore it Epstein and threatened
him while holding a power tool in a
menacing way
so drill up like let's go [__] is this
a fellow teacher no a neighbor a
neighbor is a nature is a neighbor yeah
I think it's the judge I think it's in
Spanish by the way Joni loves nachachi
sword him finally a power tool I wish we
knew what I wish we knew what power tool
it was would you want any I mean I don't
but like that's a radial saw I mean yeah
Saul's definitely more threatening oh I
mean it's a staple gun I mean it easily
just could have been a wrench it says
power power no power power wrench are
there any power wrenches it's just like
a torque wrench yeah you know so there
you go all right the judge found Epstein
replied with two middle fingers and kept
on walking so he didn't say anything
flipped up which is like the the
mid-stride and the double burner to hold
it this other bird maybe always Stone
Cold Steve Austin oh hell yeah on your
way on your way back I didn't say a word
is this the most Canadian fight ever
some guy's got a power tools like [__]
you [__] the other one like actually
flips them off and moves on nachache
alleged that Epstein also made it a
throat slashing
gesture and he learned and he feared
that Epstein would try and come back and
kill him
flip them off double you're holding them
how about saying yeah and you threatened
right the instigator is the dude with
the power tool okay it's talking [__]
you can't get arrested for a neck slap
that's like a 15-yard penalty yeah right
that's all that is in the game that's
taunting the 15 yards Sportsman like
conduct but it's not an arrestable
effect right he's not targeting not a
game all right so he this is so good
that he's going to come in and the judge
did not accept that claim wait again
you're the guy holding the drill what
are you doing on what basis did he fear
that Epstein was a potential a potential
murderer the fact that he goes on quiet
walks with his kids that says that no I
think this is me I don't know maybe the
fact that he's socialized with other
young parents on the street if that's
the stand no this is this is what he
wrote the Judgment yeah this is the fact
that he went on quiet walks with his
kids the fact that he socialized with
the other young parents on the street if
that is the standard we should all fear
that our neighbors are killers in
Waiting oh this judge straight up
mocking power saw brother he's also like
having his big moment this is like
McConaughey in a time so now do you want
to hear a little history
time to kill yeah
McConaughey and all right so neighboring
quarreling the incident was the
culmination of a series of interactions
between the two men and members of their
families so now this is a family-wide
thing we gotta feed into it with a
neighbor like unless you have to unless
it's absolutely necessary yeah but this
person is not going anywhere they're in
your life they're they're close enough
to you ignore everything even the
flip-off feels like you're look if he
was my friend I'd be like don't flip
your neighbor no our attitude in a
comedy show is that people are talking
we just ignore them as much as possible
yeah it goes so well it we wait so long
until it's a real problem before we say
anything otherwise claimed those
interactions amounted to months of
harassment but the judge found them to
be innocent Behavior to the complaints
the presence of young families outside
is a source of scorn and Vivid
resentment that ultimately spilled over
into a criminal complaint against the
neighbor the judge wrote describing
Epstein as a quote caring father of two
young daughters who come committed no
crime whatsoever that's right he called
it deplorable to the clan that the
complaints weaponized the criminal
justice system in an attempt to exert
revenge on an innocent man that's right
so is there a flop rule yeah this is
essentially the neighborhood flop rule
like this guy should get penalized for
he just hated that guy's young daughters
so much and he's like well he hated the
guy and he hated his fist families what
said like the existence of these little
girls was a source of scorn and
resentment or something for the other
guy that's right he hated him how dare
you how dare you procreate always out
there playing things Red Rover and [__]
ain't right yeah Chachi said he thought
Epstein regularly and surreptitiously
filmed him and his family okay this guy
now he's making [__] up now he's like I
gotta like make things up in reality it
was in reality the judge concluded it
was nachache who had been filming
Epstein and other neighbors from cameras
mounted outside the home which he lived
in with his parents and his brother no
nachache lives with his parents and his
brother we'll get to the ages in a
minute all right he also is worried
about he also had cameras on his damn
this will tell you a lot about him and
Trey camera on his car on his motorcycle
and in his parents cars
this guy he likes to edit this guy loves
to edit I'm gonna get like the let me
get the motorcycle shot let me get the
car shot I get the garage shot and we'll
do the top I mean I'm all for having
some cameras around your house you know
garage doorway okay but this guy is like
the reverse he's so worried about
everybody else he's watching all of them
by the way yeah and and not just
watching but instigating stuff too you
know eating his family in one incident
video submitted as evidence shows
nachache's mother Martine Martin
nachache driving dangerously near
neighborhood children she was driving
trying to run him off the road Jesus
about an hour later nachache's father
Frank nachache deliberately and
spitefully did the same so he's
basically the dad has two kids they're
like if your family if everyone in the
neighborhood right you if you have an
issue with everyone in the neighborhood
you're the issue yeah she was with you
yeah that's right that's right the
ruling says leading to a conversation
with several neighborhood fathers and
including Epstein so the so the parents
are driving close with a camera on their
car close to neighborhood and basically
with the evident producing the evidence
against them which is perfect dumpy
perfect perfect that you created the
problem and we got to make everybody
says how big of a little [__] this kid
is right let me make sure yeah so this
is the thing that happens I would bake
these people a cake a beautiful cake and
the icing would say leave the
neighborhood right now can they be mad
at you it has to be a great cake okay
incredible so delicious cake lady
fingers I'm talking on top of the cake
around like in a beautiful Circle so
Epstein testified that during the
episode franklinchochet threatened to
intentionally hit the children with this
car Michael nachache claimed in court
that Epstein assaulted his parents
during that conversation but the video
[__] you're telling me the guy went off
because you were trying to hit kids oh
[__] man but the video evidence instead
showed nachache's brother Ari nachache
pushing Epstein who then walked away in
what the oh now when we know this whole
family we know the parents Martina our
team the dad I don't know his name Frank
and Frank yeah Ari Ari and then
yeah
okay and then Epson walked away and what
the judge called a remarkable exercise
of restraint
that's right LL Neil how did LL Neil
even end up in front of a judge in the
first because this idiot brought him on
charge
for this satos wrote that Martine and
Frank nachacha should consider
themselves lucky they weren't ticketed
for reckless driving he added that the
tuna Chacha Brothers the tunicate
brothers is doesn't that sound like they
almost killed in Kirk in one of the
episodes
yeah Jay he's talking about from Happy
Days
that's what the parents are trying to do
yeah
Brothers is a phenomenal Tex-Mex
Restaurant I thought it was the prequel
to Nacho Libre all right Galia Santos
wrote it in a quick in a quitting
Epstein that he wished that he could
literally not just figuratively throw
the case out of court literally throw it
on
the specific services in this case the
court is inclined to actually take a
file and throw it out the window
which is the only way to adequately
express my bewilderment about the fact
that Epstein uh Mr Epstein was subjected
to an arrest and a fulsome criminal
prosecution the Montreal this happened
in Montreal you guys we've been to
Montreal you've been to Montreal
civilized
here's the way it would describe Mantra
I love it we were sitting having dinner
in Montreal at like 5 30 and it was a
lot of traffic because it was rush hour
not one Hawk of a horn yeah not one
remarkable in a city civilized a civil
Town yeah for this [__] to go on the
Montreal Police Service said it's
analyzing the decision and declined to
comment further so like the police might
be at it fault here so now we're going
to do this okay we're gonna guess the
ages before we get out here in this
story incredible who do you guys want to
do you want to do Michael uh natache
first or do you want to do uh let's do
Epstein last okay let's do nachache
first how old is Mike just keep calling
him LL Neil okay how old is Michael
Trey you can go first you can go in the
middle living at home he's got a
motorcycle I'll go at the end because I
have to admit you're sitting right
beside me I think I may have seen I saw
Anne age earlier so you guys go first
because I might be cheating but I'm not
sure if it's that guy's 43. if you get
into ChaCha's 43 what do you think you
think this motorcycle son of a [__]
Daniel say oh
I'm gonna go
I'll go Scotty Pippen 33 33 Okay and
because he's got anger like Scotty
I thought I saw like 34 or something
like that like Walter Payton all right
so uh
one of you is exactly right I'm gonna
guess but is one of you one year off too
one of you as one yeah
yeah Michael the judge a is 34 years so
damn but Dan was very close yeah
and you're an honorable man so all right
so we're gonna get out of this story on
this okay we'll come back we'll tell you
what we have
uh how old is LL Neil Epstein now I feel
like you should stick to your same
number here 43. do you I mean do you
yeah or were you gonna take no no I feel
like two young daughters
I did not say this guy's age but yeah
yeah his two young daughters right right
but I mean young daughters can be seven
and also what's the age at which you
either right you either think [__] you
this is enough right are you a young dad
dude or you've lived enough to be like
I'm not even dealing with you get out
right but then like like where I'm from
if you got you know two seven-year-olds
yeah right yeah yeah but in Montreal
so you already picked 43 right so I
guess I'll go how close will have to be
today
45 okay
what do you think Dan
I'm gonna go 36 years 36 years old so
hat is maybe there's 30. six and a
four-year-old yeah and they're going to
have a lot of people they're all right
get your answers in town he's because
one of you is exactly now do you want to
stay do you want to stick on 45 yeah do
you want to stick them no yeah
get your answers in and I know you
didn't see this but
all right that is the first story down
in the books we'll come back we'll tell
you what we have going on and uh find
out what Trey's got and it's not people
done with Trey Crowder we'll be right
back
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
we're before we will get to because you
have a great you have a neighborly story
I think the nachaches go down in history
as like maybe one of the dumbest
neighbors dumbest neighbors ever this
whole neighbor family whole name their
family unit although it's in the wrong
is very strong they love each other I
mean like they think they're right they
Thrive off their hate of their neighbors
uh we'll talk about this in a second we
should first just let people know that
what we have coming up
um uh again I'm not sure when this this
episode is going to drop because we'd
never know we record a bunch ahead of
time but we here so you can go so
superscars.com has all of our dates and
stuff we're doing a bunch of taggetts
we've got one which is our friends do
their stand up and then we uh pitch them
jokes afterwards on stage it's so
collaborative and fun really cool Comedy
Store on uh September 13th got gray
people on there you should come do one
soon come do the October one which would
be great Daniel's already done it it's
been fantastic we're doing Largo on the
18th and that was going to be a great
show I mean Patton and Fortune are on
that show and then two very special
guests that are huge names that we're
not announcing but just trust us when we
tell you it's going to be really good
what date is that that is on September
18th on October uh 10th we're doing a
show uh Squad brothers and friends at
the uh it's the night of a thousand
scars we're gonna do at The Bourbon Room
which we love the bedroom not a great
place yeah I did a tour date there yeah
a while back it was awesome oh and I
just the re it feels like there's a
balcony in that room Dan I first walk to
go upstairs but when you get there you
feel like you went downstairs yeah yeah
and there's also like I first walked in
like the bar area and there's like a
little area to the left that I thought
was like the stage or something yeah and
I was I was like oh [__] I don't know
about that you know but then where the
actual stage is it's great it's like a
1980s like HBO special stage oh that's a
great way to put it it's really cool so
we're gonna do that on October 10th and
then another tagging on the 8 18th we're
going to be in Springfield Missouri Fort
Collins on the fifth and sixth
reports
he's the best shout out David
he wasn't The Night Stalker no David
Rodriguez was not David that was that
was Richard Richards
Davidson he's the night Booker he's the
night Booker he's the night Booker and
he gets you he gets the everything uh
and then uh at Springfield Illinois
there's a Springfield Missouri so much
stuff superstars.com we put all the
dates on there uh Trey we should find
out like how could people hey they can
follow your podcast and whatnot see you
yeah uh yeah I got the well-read podcast
most of most of my stuff you can find
with just my name either like you can
follow me on social media just using my
name t-r-a-e Crowder on pretty much all
of them also my website Trey Crowder
t-r-a-e crowd I always have to you know
yeah
yeah uh but anyway Trae Crowder that's
where you find all my tour dates not
knowing this is coming out I don't know
but I'm all over the place throughout
the rest of the year and into 2024 so go
there and also
uh I've got a special called Damn Boy on
YouTube I love it you could watch and uh
I've got a book coming out a comedic
travel guide in September that there's a
link on my website for called round here
in Over Yonder can I tell you the native
travel guide yeah I'm already in it like
a hillbilly
but in this day and age I will say to
our fans when you know we are at right
now in uh struggle with the streaming
networks and whatnot in terms of like
you know getting getting the pay we
deserve when people put out their stuff
independently on YouTube and put out uh
their specials watch them give the power
back to The Comedians and watch these
and so that like I'm sure a lot of
people have watched it already but like
let's get these numbers up for dumb
people Town fans you will fall in love
with this guy I mean I feel like it's
like
one of the best ways to do it like
objectively at this point you know what
I mean outside of like you know just not
getting the opportunities from the big
Gatekeepers it's like it's better than
being on most of them I think because
the main thing is you want people to see
it yeah and if a lot of the other
providers people are they're not going
to see it on most of them you know other
than the big one my thing too is I think
we're just on this era of like I'm going
to give you access to this hour now
obviously if HBO or somebody you know
that's a comic stream if they go you
want to put you on yes but
apart from that I'd rather give that
hour to that access to those people and
have them come out to shows come out to
shows and become a fan of you yeah watch
his hour you'll love it and you'll check
that out Trae Crowder our name of the
special is damn boy damn boy damn Jay
let's get into one okay uh Story number
two this is sent in by Nick Bose at chef
nick80 and you know what Bose you you
pay a little bit more for it but this is
the sound quality of his food I always
use both too whenever something I'm like
this is like what Bose is for speakers
yeah it's so expensive but when you yeah
somebody has one you're like oh I guess
I understand more of a blow punked
what was that uh Crutchfield yeah yes
that was like huge in middle school or
whatever like you know we all like that
was like you're taking you're on walking
we were crazy in that that and whatever
the magazine was that had like like uh V
like truck mods in it or like Karma the
headlight mods and all that stuff and
that was always on top of the East Bay
East Bay
do you guys remember holy church yes
and it's fine everything progresses but
it is a like tactile thing that no child
like your son your your daughters will
never like being like like turning a pin
and be like I want that bat yeah and
you're just looking at it on paper
papers so we were at our cousin's place
over uh Labor Day weekend down in
Mission Viejo and they have in their
garage they've like redone the garage
and in the garage there's a pool table
and a ping pong table and it was like
cooler at night we opened up the garage
doors and they have a record player with
old speakers like it's an old school
like 70 speakers and we were just
playing records and playing ping pong
and pool all night like we played all
night it was and people were hanging out
it was just so much fun but the sound
from these old 70s speakers was so warm
and wonderful it like filled the garage
it was so cool I just loved it like I
was like this feels like us hanging out
like in the 1970s I loved it
before I forget we were talking in the
break about the the neighbors yes very
quickly like you were saying you know I
would never start [__] with my neighbor
that story made me realize like how much
it would suck to have shitty neighbors
because like yesterday I got mildly
annoyed at my neighbor because they gave
me too many passion fruits that they
grew in there like they've got and it's
like they're doing a sweet thing but I
looked at him like what am I doing what
am I gonna do with 85 passengers you
know what I mean like now I gotta figure
out how to make jam or whatever you know
what I mean but like maybe a nice thing
and I'm like I don't this is you gave me
busy work but yeah I can't imagine if
they were trying to do a vehicular
homicide on your children on the road
you know what I mean yeah that's so
great
and you're like it's a crime of passion
fruit yeah it is all right uh a GPS
mistake took a and I'm not going to tell
you how old this person was Drive driver
to the Canadian border what a lot of
Canada where he was arrested with
a certain amount of pounds of cannabis
okay and more than a certain amount of
money in his car police get so so why
don't you just say assistance in my car
do you guys need my social security
number you know this I don't know if you
know this story but like you know that's
probably what seven years ago a long
eight years ago yeah so I was waiting I
scammed I got scammed so hard I was with
my daughter on like a field trip and I
get a phone call from a number and they
just keep so you're a little frazzled I
don't know like I'm out walking because
we like walk two miles to get to the you
know 826 la which is this riding thing
and they're gonna go do a writing thing
and I finally answer and they're like
um you hear like Beeps in the background
so it feels like it's official and
whatnot and they're like you're uh
social security number has been linked
to a car that has blood drugs and money
in it at the Mexican border and I was
like and I wound up giving these people
my bank information I had to like change
everything
well that's an elaborate one I'm the
only one I've ever like answered it was
just like a dude with a thick foreign
accent being like I'm with IRS we need
Social Security number or you will lose
everything and it's like I don't think
you're with the IRS man but uh like
trying to in cocaine car at the border
right yeah
telemarketers yet on HBO no I heard it
was insane no insane it's about the
people who call for the Fraternal Order
of Police and it's just how it's okay
it's a three-part footage of these uh
yeah the Safi brothers and Danny McBride
right oh my God produced it yeah I mean
that's Danny McBride's next series it's
unreal you guys should watch oh I have
to I want to see it what happened what
happened to this successful entrepreneur
trying to make his way yeah this is his
marijuana this GPS all right an American
driver was arrested last week after he
took a wrong turn and ended up at the
Canadian border with a huge quantity of
cannabis and a lot of cash in his car
according to law enforce so this is the
ultimate version of oh [__] I think
there's a police drinking checkpoint
right when you're like can I
inconspicuously turn around because I am
not drunk at all but I did have two
cocktails even when you're not drunk
you're like how can I not go in the
second you turn around like even when
you have I've had times where I was not
even drinking and they'll do them in La
which is the wildest thing to me I've
seen them this doesn't happen in New
York or Chicago in on Melrose I don't
know like Sunday night or Wednesday
you'll do like a drinking checkpoint I'm
like what what the [__] are you guys
doing you're getting people I mean yeah
I guess I like the effort because nobody
should be on the road drinking you know
when they're impaired but even when I'm
sober I try to find a way like can I
inconspic can I turn here without them
going right go get that guy you feel
guilty the ultimate version of that is
he's at a [__] border border yeah
it's like a test turned left wound up
driving 500 miles to go can you turn
around at the border no no no
all roads are here I can't turn again
Royal Canadian mountain police said in a
news release that Andrew Lee toppenberg
his name is Andrew
he was following GPS coordinates that
were entered incorrectly when he
mistakenly ended up at the border lineup
I love GPS coordinates I know right he
wrote Taco Bell I was gonna across the
border yeah like wasn't there's a Taco
Bell is a run for the boys
I had Taco Bell the other day no you
didn't how are you feeling uh you know I
I may not be able to wait under what
circumstance would you have talk about
my daughter was like I want fast food
and we're like have you ever been to
Taco Bell and she said no and
you want to guess my daughter's never
been to time never do you want to guess
my order Dorito uh taco shell taco with
what with meat cheese and no lettuce
that's exactly right I got two Doritos
and my daughter and my wife got
Crunchwrap Supremes I was going to guess
crunch traps yeah we did we got them
every girl breakfast oh no the like oh
yeah I mean your daughter University of
Michigan but within a week we'll have
breakfast pizza no no just the standard
Mexican pizza at Taco where are you at
on Taco but obviously you guys are busy
oh I'll I'll I will I'll rush me too
dude I have it probably I mean at this
point in my life I don't know once a
month or something but still like easily
once a month probably when I'm on the
road doing shows there's times you have
to eat and you're like I will gladly it
was really [__] I'm just gonna say
I'm in Springfield Missouri after the
light show or whatever like I'm not
going to find a blue room now we're
going there
for what things that are probably open
unless it's a diner Taco Bell's a good
option it made me think of our users so
we used to go out in our youth and we'd
be drunk in our in our whatever and high
school high school and we'd show up at
Taco Bell drunk roll out of our buddy
Matt Fox truck and we would each order
10 tacos easily five sauce because you
guys like innovated the taco box
each had a taco box
each one each of us had one they weren't
in bags they were in boxes and we'd eat
them down and then be so drunk the room
is spinning later you throw them back up
and they look like it did when it went
down uh so he he this is it was
following GPS coordinates that were
entered incorrectly when he mistakenly
ended up at the border lineup at
Canada's Rainbow Bridge border crossing
in Niagara Falls Ontario what whoops
that's like I mean it's lucky he didn't
drive over the falls I know uh Tom
brings you to Canada an accident yeah a
mistake toppenberg of coordinates wasn't
there a place in St Louis Offenburg
Auffenberg often Auffenberg is very big
very big in Belleville Illinois uh
tomberg of test in California was
subject to an inspection because he did
not have to passport with him well why
would he have his passion he's not
trying to go there no he didn't think he
was crossing the border I I don't give a
[__] about weed at all right and I
assume I'm assuming that's what this is
and it's money too right
I think you should be able to get to a
border and if you're like
didn't mean to do this I'm just kind of
turning right back around they they
should they should be able to go yeah
you can go right back yeah like you're
not trying because I don't want to go
through so you don't get to check me
they should just send me in the loop
around you're not trying to get into
their country right it needs to be
Eternal or the punishment is you have to
wait till all these cars go through for
seven hours and then you can leave so
you made a mistake and you got to deal
with what he should have done I'd rather
get around when he realized he was in
line he should have turned his car off
got out a whole bunch of like uh you
know people popped his hood oh my God I
don't know you're gonna get one nice
person going back into Canada like what
do you want to do and he's like you know
what just let's I'm sorry guys but let's
just push it back because once I get
into Canada and then how I get my car
fixed
and then they're gonna be like what are
you doing you know and he's like oh I
planned on coming up to you guys about
my car I can't obviously I'm not
supposed to be so long before it yeah
for a hockey game what are you doing up
there that would be it yeah I'm not
saying it would go wrong but to me that
is your best bet that you have a bigger
problem that has nothing to do going to
Canada this is a genius and you just
need help pushing your car back Canadian
border officials said they found how
much how many pounds how many pounds of
a kilogram of cannabis during their
inspection
well what are we going with
how do they allowance we'll do pounds
pounds how many pounds of can I have
both three three pounds I was gonna say
five five pounds I believe in this
[__] I'm gonna go
three pounds is a lot I know I know but
like three like it seems like it's a
whole number of I agree no I mean I
think five here's what I think if he is
that far north
he is trying to get he has a long way to
go to distribute right I just don't
think you're unloading a lot in The
Dakotas right or Buffalo right so low
he's a buffalo yeah right so
he he when you first get your weed
you're gonna have the most of it because
you haven't gotten anywhere with this
this is another run I'm gonna say he 20
pounds 20 pounds that's a trash bag full
of weeds that is it's a trash bag all
right so get your answers in at home you
said 20 you said five five I said three
yeah this man was caught with 399 pounds
so first of all what do you think that's
valued at quick guess what do you think
it's valued at
399 pounds a week I've never bought from
a dealer eight hundred thousand dollars
two million
I'll split it 1.4
775. I have no idea to 539 000 that's I
I thought it was way more I said 800.
they all got found almost 400 pounds of
wages only worth well so they also found
cash so he has I guess been selling
along the way yeah or buying or buying
how much cash did they find in this car
60 Grand ah God damn it yeah because I I
was I would have said more but now
knowing what the value is I'm thinking
like like the 40 you say 40 Grand yeah
I'm gonna say something commodity is
down doesn't it it must be yeah right 78
they found six hundred thousand dollars
none of this math get away from the
border dude get away from this listen
the drugs and the money were located
throughout the car of course with
cannabis and vacuum pack containers yes
and the cash separated into bundles that
were concealed in a safe suitcase
lockable case according to the police
dude don't go to the order
right because if you get pulled over
based off what you said I'm pretty sure
they need a warrant for that stuff yeah
but when you're at a border checkpoint I
don't think they need a warrant for
anything no why would you even be close
to a Border Town if you're holding this
much [__] in your car like Buffalo nice
to get high too I agree
if you are at the northern part of
anywhere in this country and you are
heading east or west you should never
turn north no exactly too close to go
north it's like it's like when you're
lost in a place like where you're like a
like an Ocean Resort and you just always
know well if we go that way that's the
ocean so I know we need to go the
opposite way right he's like well that's
Canada so I'm I'm having I'm heading
east I will never turn left it's a
bridge thing too well you said it right
yeah the Rainbow Bridge that should have
also felt wrong yeah exactly exactly we
feel like I should be crossing a
gigantic Bridge that's close to Niagara
Falls I would Jump Right In The Water uh
the police said the packaging look like
sort of containers drug dealer or money
launderers use of course that makes
sense uh hold on a second and then they
said uh which then LED them to issuing
charges against tottenberger on
suspension of Suspicion of possession
and the import of cannabis and
possession more than five thousand
dollars knowing that all parts of the
proceeds were obtained by CR by a crime
tobenberg appeared in Ontario Ontario
Court on Monday and remained in custody
Jeff Walters director of Niagara
District Operations for Canada's Border
Services he's coming down from Canada
into the cbsa this is what he said in a
statement the cbsa is extremely proud of
the diligence shown by our officers the
hard work has a profound impact on
continually ensuring Public Safety at
our board we sold the weed and now we
can have the officers Christmas party
that's right so I mean I mean that much
weed it's not you guys no disrespect but
a dog four times over smelled that way
that's right they smelt it coming from
like 20 cars they probably checked every
car in the lineup yeah like this guy
screwed everybody's trip in they're like
we smell we smell weed for the last mile
so you got to tell us who's got yeah we
knew you were coming the dogs are going
nuts or it's bad weed in which case
you're like if we can't smell it what
are you selling bro it might be bad weed
because that's the value I'm about to
say the numbers yeah yeah that's right
is that just like what the mark like all
the you know because you can get weed
soda and lollipops and stuff just ruined
the market for yeah like why wouldn't
you come across the border with like 800
000 lollipops and just be like look well
it seems like it is an odd choice to
still be in the weed game specifically
across the border with that much stuff
whatever it is Brownies you know
lollipops they would be like this you
have an intent to sell something and so
you gotta check it through this is why
you gotta declare [__] when you're
flying from another country back into
our country like you don't have the
intent to sell it's it's a big big
problem we're gonna get out of here on
this okay how old is Andrew Lee
toppenberg Andrew Lee how old is this
cat
who thought he could take six hundred
thousand dollars and foreign
that's really good because if they took
cord like uh coordinates from him like
that's what he said yeah you know where
he's like yeah put it in the wrong
coordinates okay so I think he probably
is younger but just because I've said
all that and why not I'll say he's like
76.
I'm gonna go with an idiot who is 24
years old I think but that's but he's a
24 year old got somebody gives 24 that
much weight but I think he's 34. but I
do think like that the Clint Eastwood
movie should have been called the fork
the fork ball yeah Fork ball like
because he's at a Crossroads in his life
yes all right get your you said 76. yeah
I said 24 and I said
34. all right
get your answers in shout at your ham
radios this guy Andrew Lee toppenberg is
60 years
your GP at your mental GPS LED you to
the right place yeah so good so good
years do you know was he a like a
veteran of this or is like is he a or is
he like new to the Leo fight yeah maybe
60 like it's a Breaking Bad or did
somebody else
like the notion that like the like the
highest level CIA agents who are like
undercover look like just normal people
yeah because they're the least suspected
like Air Marshals or people just maybe
they're like let's send this dude down
because I don't say anything Andrew Lee
tobenberg this is his he got divorced
from his first wife this is his second
marriage married someone much younger
than him yeah and she's like who also
has like a teenage son so she's like 34
and has like a impressive kid and he's
got to get your own kid and he's like
I'm trying to be cool stepdad in the new
situation trying to be cool for the wife
who's 40 years younger than a man the
kid yeah there you go now
all right Dana give us a taste of what
we're going to see in uh segment three
oh it's a a very unusual house break-in
I love it very unusual housebreaking
it's dumb people Town Drake routers with
us we'll be right back
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get to the final story Daniel let
people know where they can see he's got
a bunches much like the the scars I
don't know when this is dropping you
should go to Daniel van kirk.com uh I'm
on the road I'm hitting the Midwest I'm
hitting the South I'm hitting the East
Coast I'm headlining yuck Fest in Boston
at the end of October and it's all
leading up do what you're doing yuck
Fest dude you're not going to believe it
um leading up to my special taping on 11
11 at the Lincoln Lodge in Chicago
that's going to be Illinois that is
going to be a post well it's a double
party because the night before I'm
headlining Rochelle Illinois before that
I'm in Louisville but all that stuff is
at
danielvankirk.com and when I'm on the
road any of you townies bring a dumb
headline with you because I open up the
show by asking if anybody has a headline
or a uh a pen pals postcard go to
danielvangirk.com and you know what the
last thing can I can I put out a uh like
a the cork board for our town you know
when you go to the grocery store and
you're like up there yeah uh somebody's
always getting rid of dirt I'm like
why'd you move I've got 70 pounds of
dirt if anybody out there is a townie
who knows WordPress I need help with my
site because when you go to scroll oh
God if you're on a mobile it it won't
show all my dates yeah you have to be on
a desktop and I there's not a lot of
grandparents just did a story about a
guy who didn't know GPS now you don't
know WordPress I know that my site's not
working so I don't need a full redesign
I just need somebody who goes boom that
helped the scrolling all I know is I
tried to use WordPress and I got stopped
tweeted pay you in handshakes okay all
right uh also join our patreon we have a
great patreon I'm gonna say that it's
really fun another great way to support
trying to get to artists the two levels
of a hot chip challenge yeah let's do it
I'll do it at whatever 500 and then
we'll get it we get a thousand patreons
it's also a jam and a hang yeah it's so
fun we love it and it's only five what
is it five bucks a month that's it
nothing all right okay come do that all
right here we go Daniel take us home
ready yep sent in by brewpounder at
brewpounder Brew pounder Brew pound
person loves the Brew I don't need
Milwaukee right I was sick of Wisconsin
yeah yeah Brew pounder is the Trey
Crowder of beer drinking yeah
oh yeah family says cows broke into
their new house in Montana not true not
true you say not true not true they
didn't break in
okay the family is making it seem like
there's intent yeah right yeah cows are
like they broke in they're mad at us one
of the pictures that I'm going to show
you at some point in the story does kind
of feel like this cow's like got your
ass yeah you should have been here
[__] I wouldn't have been around
cows yeah a little bit they don't tend
to do many beats but all the way in a
cow okay you did that yeah
in high school that's Rochelle baby I uh
they were there I was doing Agriculture
and Science and one day they had a cow
brought in and they said this is how we
artificially inseminate a cow and the
guy went he went shoulder deep into the
back end of a cow and then he goes is
there any would anybody else like to try
it and I remember even at the age of 17
thinking to myself I have to you will
never get asked this question again in
your life to do it and much like when
people see people that they really
admire Sports athletes and stuff like
that I always go this could be the time
you saw that person or the time you met
that person right and this could be the
time I saw this cow or I intimately met
this guy you know this do they you put a
whole sleeve on him all the way deep in
so warm and it also messed me up
sexually for like what I'm into oh not
animals but I just want a warm arm one
of them
come on yeah I mean yeah I can't match
that I did work with a guy right after
high school who claimed to uh have had
sexual relations with cows that is
horrible I hope you just hit him in the
face
fire to him first of all if you saw him
and heard him and everything he just
thought that did his name well you know
like look at tracked yeah like yes but I
was working for the Clay County highway
department it was mostly Old redneck
guys I was 18 years old he and they
could have all been [__] with you of
course that is actually more likely yeah
like he would go into like like he said
he had one train so good when he opened
the gate
sorry that's what he told me but that's
that's such a good line yeah right I
have to believe that I had her trained
so good I opened up the door flipped the
light on the Tailwind yeah and you're
like I hate to correct you it's trained
so well but that's fine hey that's what
the line is in Fifty Shades of Gray
black and white okay yeah hilarious so
are there any like geographical tensions
with the you know because in Montana
it's like look at all these California
people living up there like are these
California people and the cows are
pissed off they're trying to keep time
kind of weird yeah right exactly in
Montana Montana a Washington family was
shocked to discover that bovines moved
they wrote that into their new house in
Montana a poster on reddit's well that
sucks which if anybody is going for am I
the [__] I'm pretty sure well that
sucks we'll probably have some good dump
people
counties on the ground well that sucks
section shared pictures of a new home
that was taken over by cattle quote this
big guy and three of his friends got
into our newly built Montana house and
proceeded to live there for how long
before being found hit me with it quick
uh two weeks uh how long are these guys
ten days a winter
for a month oh my God uh because these
are these are these are they're watches
they don't live in Montana
yeah yeah it's like the Ozarks when
people just yeah he might be right there
several commenters said the house might
very well need to be gutted and
re-flored due to the damage and urge the
poster to talk to an insurance company
yeah uh in a response to people's
questions the poster wrote one house is
on my aunt's property we currently live
in Washington and we're planning to move
over at the end of the year sure we
assumed she was going down and this is
where you start to throw yourself
she was going down every now and again
which is a casual way of saying she told
us she was going down every now again
but apparently someone oh you're right
that comma you just did in your own
sentence we assumed she was going down
to check on the house comma yes she
wasn't cattle guy has a lot of passive
aggressive at her cattle guy has a lot
of acreage sorry and look for his cows
even filed a report for stolen cattle he
looked in our shed but not the house
because he thought someone was living it
was like when you hit a hole in one and
you're like I can't find
so the cattle guy picture him he goes
maybe they're on their property old
aunt's property he even looks in the
shed no he must have looked and the
cattle had set up some sort of Home
Alone mannequin
to be like well they're the only humans
in here
these are like the Chick-fil-A
spell it wrong
quote uh number two I'm sorry there was
a bad storm in town I think in late
April and we think the cows were looking
for coverage they either got in by
nudging a level door or the wind might
have blown the door open right amazing
if the wind blew the door open then the
cows must have been like they want us
Gaia wants us to go into it yeah we
knocked and again we asked our Aunt to
make sure all the doors are pretty close
[Applause]
he also says number three insurance has
been contacted but I'm not sure about
outcome because my stepdad is trying to
deal with it directly with the cattle
guy newspapers like okay we don't need
it all right but why are they print it
my stepdad who really doesn't check his
voicemail
about my step dad it also means that his
stepdad is trying to strong arm the
cattle guy and to take a responsibility
for this when it's like you check your
house yes more than a month yeah step
dad when he gets a couple in him he
starts to get confrontational why is
this in the Arts right we got him off
ice house so he's not as strong a beer
anymore but he's still mad mostly water
uh I'm going to become a vegetarian this
is number five to please the cow God so
this will never happen again uh you
tried a joke and it's hilarious it's
unclear where the house is located it'll
learn more I will show you the picture
of these cows we'll put them on I'll
show you the first one right
you can see the floor
because they're kicking [__] and then
here's the one with the cow that just
kind of feels like what what do you want
but this looks like that it's just [__]
on the wall everywhere and everywhere I
mean that house is done that house is
finished it's done right yeah that house
is just or you have to live your house
like a farm where anytime anyone comes
over you go you'll get used to this how
thrilled those cows must have been the
cows
he must be my birthday this is the
greatest time ever yeah yes this is like
the hangover when they're in Mike
Tyson's Suite yeah this is these cows we
don't belong in here yeah oh I love it
all right that story there you go 43
down in the books again uh I'm so
excited well-read podcast check that out
check out his special damn boy on
YouTube uh books coming out soon that
will be called round here and Over
Yonder on Forester me and him
smart dude great comedy glad you were
here we got to get back to work guys
[Music]